this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show we help you get control of your
money get ahead in your career and get
on the path to living well i'm ramsey
personality george campbell joined today
by fellow ramsay personality and
best-selling author christina ellis and
we are so pumped to take your call so
give us one why don't you triple eight
eight two five five two two five
this is a momentous day christina
because it's our first time co-hosting
together yes i'm so excited it's a day
you've been think dreaming of since you
were a little girl i'm sure i know one
day
i'll host the show with jordan no no one
dreams of the infamous george campbell
but this is exciting so we uh we're
going to take your questions your money
your life your career your relationships
student loans college we want to talk
about all of it the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
david kicks us off this hour in
jacksonville florida david welcome to
the show
oh thank you so much for having me yeah
sure how can we help
all right so i just had a question about
my rent and whether or not i
whether or not it's reasonable for me to
be paying what i pay uh given how i'm in
in a unique
circumstance okay how unique
um so
i currently make around 59 500
uh before taxes um
per year
uh and my
rent is
seven hundred eighty eight dollars per
month ouch
yeah
tell me about it
um
yeah and
you know so my net pay
my net take-home pay after taxes
and like health care deductions and all
that is
right around
three thousand nine hundred and fifty
five dollars okay i believe
and
so if i do the math to that
is
around
i think 45 percent
yep exactly brilliant yeah
okay exactly but
the interesting thing is that i don't
have any i'm very very fortunate and
that i don't have any student loan
or credit card debt or like a car
payment so you have no debt whatsoever
uh correct okay the hesitation worried
me i was like what are you hiding david
what do you got
so no doubt whatsoever all of your
income goes to you but again you're
saying hey this my take-home pay uh
after rent comes out i got real barely
anything
left over
right yeah that's did it recently go up
no it's it's been going on for
for a while um
and is it a one bedroom apartment what
are we talking
it's a one one-bedroom apartment okay
are there alternatives in the area that
are cheaper what's kind of the market
like where you're at
uh yeah that's the thing is that um i
looked at some other places
where i live um so i i ride where i live
right now i want to just you know to
move to a place near the office
you know just take on gas
um i mean like the good news is like i
can walk to the office where i work at
um so it's a good benefit
um are you saying yeah there aren't that
many
yes okay
how is it fitting in your budget right
now are you are you feeling pretty
stressed are you barely making it to the
end of the month like what's it feel
like how's it fitting with the rest of
your expenses
uh
yeah it's uh
yeah i do feel stressed um and
do you have an emergency fund
oh yeah absolutely yeah it's um
yeah yeah it's savings wise i'm okay
it's just i just don't like spending
more than i make
sure well you're currently not doing
that right it sounds like you're living
on less than you make there's just not
much left at the end of the month
exactly are you investing 15
into retirement
i can't i can't do that i mean i i think
it's
oh well well are you talking about like
401k wise
percentage of percentage of like my
paycheck yes are you investing currently
uh
i currently
ha do three percent i believe yeah three
percent is that a match
yeah okay but you're not investing
beyond the three percent
right that just because rent is so
expensive
so where's all the other money going i
mean it's just you're trying to cover
bills i mean you don't sound like you're
living frivolously here but how much
money is left at the end of the month
because you should have some margin if
you have no debt
right um
i think around like 500
okay and where is that 500 going
currently i just just in my savings
account in my checking account okay
if i'm in your shoes i'm going to up
that to 15
and that might mean you have less
margin at the end of the month are you
doing a budget every month currently
uh
sometimes okay
not every month i think that's going to
really help you feel like you have some
control over where your money's going
because right now it's just a lot of
emotion and just it feels tight but
you're not sure why and when you start
paying attention to where every single
dollar is going it has a signed job and
a category that's going to be a huge
help so i'm going to gift you one year
of our premium budgeting tool every
dollar so that you can get on that path
and figure out where every dollar is
going and hopefully you'll find some
money in the couch cushion there you
know uh proverbially speaking
yeah and i would also just think about
like what are your goals how
aggressively do you want to say
personally i would feel pretty nervous
having my housing cost be 45
of my take-home pay so i mean you could
consider maybe moving if you want to
really stay close to work maybe you
could get a two-bedroom and have a
roommate and split the cost and it'll be
a little bit less per month for each of
y'all or maybe you could
you could live five minutes away from
work and drive or maybe find somewhere
where you could bike to work that's a
little bit cheaper um especially if
you're hoping to like save up a down
payment or have money for retirement you
know i'd probably look into it yeah we
need to figure out this situation and go
can i move further out are there other
apartments in the area that are cheaper
can i find a roommate and split the cost
to where it's now 25 30 percent of my
take-home pay that'd make me feel a
whole lot better
would you be willing to get a roommate
oh absolutely um
the only thing is i don't quite
know many people in the area except for
you know people that are at work um
and
are your co-workers feeling the same
pinch have you talked to them about this
and see hey what do you pay for him
where do you live
oh absolutely yeah some of them have
told me you know um that rent is crazy
you know
um
well i feel like yeah
especially especially nowadays there's
so many ways to find roommates i love
your idea of you know checking out if
co-workers are looking for roommates but
there's also facebook groups in the
community there are apps available like
nowadays especially jacksonville i mean
that's a populated area with a lot of
young people how old are you
i'm 25. oh sweet yeah there's got to be
another 25 year old out there i mean the
age doesn't really matter but i want an
18 year old moving in with you or you
know a 75 year old so maybe find some
somewhere who someone who's in your same
kind of stage of life um that you can
figure out a way to shave down those
costs but i think right now i'd up the
investing you have the money there i
wouldn't just waste it sitting in a
savings account um when you already have
your emergency fund i'd rather have that
growing with compound interest so that
when you're 65 you're thanking me later
for the millions of dollars in that
account thanks for the call man i know
rent's a tough one right now christina
is up everywhere
but florida especially it's bad yeah
stressing a lot of people out
thanks for the call david appreciate it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by
ramsay personality christina ellis and
we are taking your calls america the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five
five two two five
well we are headed back out on the road
we've done a few events earlier this
year and the fall is going to be
jam-packed so imagine the energy of an
arena filled with people who are ready
to experience what it means to live life
to the fullest now picture all of your
favorite speakers on a stage empowering
you with tools and principles that will
create unstoppable momentum in your life
that is smart conference it's been three
years since we've done this event and it
is seriously my favorite event we do
here at ramsey and we're pumped to get
it back on the road in dallas texas on
saturday october 22nd this is not just
another pep talk this is thousands of
people like you coming together under
one roof to learn how to build wealth
achieve their goals strengthen
relationships and so much more and we
have a good time too it is very
entertaining we pull out all the stops
for this one all of us ramsay
personalities will be there including
christina ellis to my right and some
special guests craig and amy grishall
from life church they'll be there as
well event passes start at just 39 bucks
for an all-day event that's amazing and
there's no ticket master fees which
would crank it up you know double that
so that's the good news inflation has
not hit us here at ramsey solutions so
go get your passes before they sell out
ramsey solutions.com events is the place
to go
josh joins us up next in hattiesburg
mississippi josh welcome to the show
oh yes i have a question i don't know if
i'm in bad shape or good shape i feel
like i'm in good shape financially so
let's
yeah okay just make sure we're talking
the same page here
yes yes uh let me just start with the
bad first okay i owe a hundred and
ninety thousand dollars on my farm
okay i owe 54 000 on my truck
i owe 32 000 on a piece of equipment and
about 28 thousand 000 on another piece
of equipment
now after taxes i bring home 150 000
sometimes a little more if i work more
in my bank account i have 360 thousand
dollars in a loft ri i have six hundred
thousand dollars in my 401k i have 1.1
million whoa and on my father
and i'm a farmer account i have 392 000
my question is should i pay my farm off
and lose all the tax credits i get from
the federal government every year
or should i just keep going like i'm
going
well do you like where you're headed
well my numbers
always say good but i don't ever spend
nothing i don't own a house
i don't
i don't know just how would it feel
though got it picture this josh how'd it
feel making 150 thousand dollars
and the only person you owe is uncle sam
and after that you take all of that home
and you get to do what you want with it
it's not going back out to the
automotive lender it's not going back
out on the equipment loans the farm loan
how would that feel
well i've always said if everything's
paid off and i had five hundred thousand
dollars just in my bank account i would
be happy
you have the money you just told me in
the bank to pay this off today all of it
right the equipment
so far and it's worked out
but the moment that it's not the case
yeah so you you've dug yourself into a
hole but you got a big shovel
yeah and so you've been safe because of
that but
man i just i look at your picture and i
go you're doing so well in so many areas
you don't need that
just don't think okay you're a
millionaire who's a very successful
farmer
you've got a great head on your
shoulders you've got an incredible work
ethic and so if i subtract debt out of
that picture i get real excited about
josh's future
yeah i do too but i'm all
i don't know i watch too much news and
i'm always worried about inflation will
this even
but when i get older when i'm in my 60s
or 70s the lord lets me to live that
long will i live comfortable then
you know
will i be able to live comfortable
you can live comfortable right now you
don't have to wait till you're 70. if we
get this debt out of your life it's a
whole new picture and you're not if you
think you're scamming the government
getting those tax credits man you can do
so much better than that the white house
is not blessing you josh has blessed you
the lord has blessed you with this
incredible work ethic and this business
you're running and so i'm not doing
nothing for the tax credit
in other words just
pay everything off and just go with like
i've been doing dude you could be
completely debt free today
own the farm outright own the truck
outright own the equipment outright it's
going to ride differently
yeah but
i don't know if you know much about
farming after about i don't know eight
or nine years equipment starts breaking
and all that and what i do is i just
turn around to get a brand new one that
way it ain't working over there well i
don't know much about farming but i know
a whole lot about debt and i know how it
steals from your income and that it's a
thief and it robs you from your future
and you just work too hard to be dealing
with this mess
yeah true you're not a broke farmer you
don't need to be carrying around
payments the rest of your life well it
sounds like you're a little nervous
about the economy and inflation
inflation and one of the best ways to
protect yourself is to be debt free like
having debt that is a risk when crap
hits the fan and you owe no one nothing
it changes how you make decisions josh
yeah you're not freaking out trying to
sell things out of deal
yeah for being as young as i am i think
i'm doing good i ain't 35 and i think
i've got a hope of everything right now
you're doing great well what's so great
is you are still young so you're talking
about you know as you get older are you
going to be at any risk and it's like
right now you could be debt-free and
continue to build like this is you you
know you have so much time ahead of you
to keep building and building your
savings and building your retirement
you're already doing so awesome but to
do it without debt is just going to be
that much more powerful
and if you want to get angry at it look
at the interest you're paying on this
300 000 worth of debt
i got to a federal grant loan
the farm the truck all of the equipment
is all zero percent
yup
i don't believe it
not first
yes sir yes sir so if you could take out
another half million at zero percent
today would you do it
oh no i wouldn't take that no no then
let's get rid of the current one
because you have 300 000 sitting there
with zero percent man i'm telling you
when those payments don't go back out
when they stay with you it's going to
change everything it's going to change
your spirit it's going to change your
mentality your mindset
it's going to take a literal stress off
of your body
yeah like i got the money but you know
just going back down to zero but yet
being debt free
you're not going to zero dude
you owe people money it looks like
you're doing well because you have a
bunch of money in the bank but
that money has a name on it well you're
not going anywhere close to zero right
you said you have
six hundred thousand
you got 360k in the bank you got a you
got a lot of money sitting around bud
so
well you know i my grandma really helped
me you know like she really showed me
how to be frugal and all that and
reading my bible and i read it and i
just i just listened to god a lot and he
just
i've always gotten by i've never bought
a house i've never done that never went
to college i never took out more than
what i did
and
in the last five years is when i
accumulated my debt but i made sure i
had my money
and i didn't pay it off because somebody
told me oh you get these tax credits
from the federal government who's
it wasn't god or grandma i'll tell you
that much no
no it wasn't it was another farmer which
he went bankrupt so maybe i'm thinking
well maybe we shouldn't take financial
advice from that farmer maybe we should
listen to god and grandma which is how
we run this show gods and grandma's ways
of handling money and if you read that
bible years it'll say the borrower is
slave to the lender doesn't it
yes sir and it doesn't feel like it
because you've been able to out earn
this
yeah cause you've got a pile of money
you've been doing some things really
diligently and really well but you could
be doing way better if you cleaned up
this mess and you can do it today that's
the best part there's not a lot of
sacrifice you're just moving some money
out of a bank account paying off your
debt
end of the day you're debt
free all right with sanji but now i know
what i should do
now
josh you're crushing it man i appreciate
the call
wow yeah that's impressive that's it's
rare christina to see a guy who's doing
so well
he's got over a million dollars sitting
in retirement accounts he's got so much
money in the bank but he's hanging on to
the debt thinking it's a blessing in his
life
and so it's a simple fix this is a great
situation to be in yep he's not broke
he's got a great income he's got plenty
of money in the bank
game on
now let's live our life with freedom
from now on that's what i want for josh
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five this is the
ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined by christina
ellis today this is the ramsay show give
us a call triple eight eight two five
five two two five
on the line we've got james and katie
from ocean city new jersey and i see on
my screen that you guys are debt free
that's right we love to see it how much
debt did you pay off
uh 389 000 whoa and how long did that
take
about four years
okay making uh what range of income
during that time
we were
at 130 to 548.
okay what do you guys do for a living
well um i have like a little side hustle
and i take care of the kids and
i help with real estate
i'm in real estate aha
and apparently things have been going
well the last few years
yes they have the past two years have
been
really good
we live at a beach resort so it
really took off and everyone's trying to
escape to the beach these days so this
all uh residential real estate
uh yes residential real estate yep good
for you well you must be a rockstar real
estate agent that is awesome
okay thank you so tell us about the 389
000 debt what kind was it
um let's see we had credit card debt and
we had a rental property that was losing
money every month
um
and our house and a lot of stupid
investments whoa so you paid off all
this debt and decided let's just pay off
the house too
that's right that's incredible way to go
guys
how old are you two
i'm 45 and i just turned 40. oh my
goodness and you've got a beautiful
family if you're watching on youtube you
can see them and the in the pup as well
what a picture perfect family
this is incredible so tell us about this
journey four years ago you guys had a
great income you were living a normal
life credit cards you had you know
rental property investment debt and your
mortgage what happened four years ago
that got you set on this path
uh so about six years ago
i had taken a team leader position
in a different state
we relocated our family and
during that year
we ended up going broke
the
job brought me to my knees i ended up
having
a relapse and our marriage was falling
apart
wow
that was six years ago
yep and so you started kind of climbing
out of that with recovery and trying to
keep this marriage afloat
yeah we we ended up moving back home
and um
had a lot of people around us for
support i was in groups and
we were in counseling for a while um
and
we just had a lot of people come into
our lives and
just got close to god and had him guide
us through it
that's incredible and how did you get
connected to us
um well during that time it was
obviously really challenging
and
when we found dave ramsey that was like
the first step to rebuilding our
marriage we were
pulling on the same rope for the first
time probably in our whole marriage
and uh we're not exactly sure but i
think we stumbled on the podcast and
then i have uh
the side hustle business that's cleaning
and um
as i was scrubbing toilets and cleaning
up after everyone's fabulous vacations i
would always listen to the podcast
and that was like my why um for
getting out of the debt and jimmy
didn't help me clean toilets but he did
the same yeah a lot of sacrifice was
made and i mean you guys were just we're
going we're going to fix this marriage
we're going to get our health back and
we're going to get our money back what
would you say was the hardest part of
paying off the debt
i i just staying
focused um
what helped was just the little wins
we never
i think we had a vision of like paying
off our house but it wasn't real clear
like yeah that's a distant future kind
of thing
um but your the system works um so we
just got little wins along the way which
created the momentum
and realized like there is a path to to
make it happen
i love that little wins especially you
all talked about how you know you had
just been through so much in that season
job loss and addiction and all of that
and to see those little wins it's like
it doesn't have to be major it doesn't
have to be all at once but to make that
incremental progress is powerful
that's awesome i love what katie said
you guys started pulling on the same
rope
you started going in the same direction
and you started feeling that progress
when you get on the same page you guys
are incredible so what's the house worth
around 450.
i love it and it's all yours
that's right yep
did you all have some cheerleaders in
the process
we did
um my parents
were huge in
encouraging us and just supporting us
through that challenging time and my dad
always loved talking about money our
pastor
and his wife ron and stephanie
[Music]
mike and joel um we go to church with
them and we would always have fun with
dave ramsey-isms just laughing about
stuff and
our families just were always a big
support to our sisters that's huge never
underestimate the importance of having
the right people in your corner cheering
you on
not just for money but for life
yeah absolutely yeah they were a big
part of that
so talk to that couple that may be
facing some of the stuff you guys were
facing six years ago the mayor just hang
on by a thread there's addiction you
just feel like this will never get
better what do you say to that couple
what is the key to getting out of debt
um
so
yeah uh what i kind of go back to is
opportunity comes dressed in overalls
and looks a lot like work
he loves saying that
i love that also
and um just speaking the stuff in into
light too because that's where
god is real powerful he shows up we we
get it out of inside of us in those deep
dark spots
and uh to speak it into light and he'll
show up
that's powerful it reminds me of the
quote pray like it all depends on god
work like it all depends on you and you
guys were a great a great mix of that
and you got plugged into your church
community
and you just set yourselves on a path
where you said no more and now you have
this incredible income you have this
beautiful family and you get to keep it
all you get to leave a legacy and change
your family tree so proud of you guys
how does it feel how does it feel to
feel to be completely debt free
um it feels great i mean we definitely
struggled when we paid off we paid our
last mortgage payment because we were
like okay now now what like what are we
doing now um because we were so focused
on that for
you know rebuilding our marriage working
on our financial issues and so we're in
the season where we're like okay
now that what are we gonna do the kids
have lots of ways we can spend our money
oh yeah well now it's vacations and
college funds and building for the
future and building wealth and being
outrageously generous
that's right giving for sure i love it
well we're gonna send you guys a copy of
dave's number one bestselling book baby
steps millionaire how how uh every day
people build extraordinary wealth and
how you can too we're also going to send
you the total money makeover to get
someone else set on their journey to
financial freedom and we're going to
gift you guys one year financial peace
university and our premium budgeting
tool every dollar and it's all included
in ramsey plus we're going to give that
to you guys you can use it yourselves or
gift it to someone else
awesome thank you it's the moment we've
all been waiting for james and katie
ocean city new jersey 389 000 paid off
house and everything in four years
making 130 all the way up to 548 000
crushing the real estate game count it
down guys let's hear a debt-free scream
you ready three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
you can hear the children in the
background i'm pretty sure i heard the
dog in there too they were all jumping
for joy that's powerful that's inspiring
i mean beating addiction restoring a
marriage getting completely debt free
that's a good day in my book that's a
whole journey if you needed some good
news you just got some
transformation is always inspiring and
it's out there for you america it's
available to you you can do it you just
got to put in the work like james and
katie did it's possible this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ramsay
personality and best-selling author
christina ellis and if you've seen
borrowed future the documentary you put
out christina was featured in it with
her amazing story of getting a half
million dollars in scholarships going to
college completely debt free and your
masters as well
pretty amazing story christina oh yes
thank god it was such a blessing and i'm
honored to get to share with students
now about how they can go to school
debt-free too so many people think that
the only way it's debt you have to take
out a student loan it's totally normal
and
i'm glad my story is proof that that's
not true i'm glad that there's other
stories in the documentary of people who
went you know what i'm taking loans off
the table and i'm gonna figure out a way
to go debt free and it's just it's
inspiring and i think it's so important
for students to see this because we got
to fight this toxic culture that says
that's the only way that student loans
are quote good debt because it rois
right you're gonna make so much money if
you have a degree you'll pay it off in
no time
oh boy and here we are 20 years later
people are still paying down their
student loans the interest is climbing
the balance is higher than when they
started
and they're going please help white
house someone fixed this for me right
that's a huge problem huge problem and
part of why i'm so passionate about
helping this younger generation is
because i see
my friends i see people my age who
bought into that lie and they thought
you know it's all going to work out but
of course i'm going to get a great job
i'm going to pay this off easily all the
adults in my life at 17 told me
that it's going to work out and
assumptions a lot of assumptions and now
they're dealing with the pain and
they're putting off getting married
they're putting off buying a house major
life decisions because they feel trapped
by student loan debt and i think we've
got to do better for the next generation
well we are glad you're here to be the
preventative medicine for this next
generation and help them avoid that trap
love it triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to call we'd
be happy to take it luke joins us up
next in salt lake city utah luke welcome
to the show
hey it's an honor to be
on the show we're happy to have you
what's going on so i'm 14. i'm the ones
around my neighborhood i make about 130
a week
and uh
so i know it's not a ton of money but i
do have some and i was wondering if it'd
be a good idea to invest some of it
what's your situation luke i mean you
have expenses for this business you're
running
uh no just uh there's something to get
money
do you have any money in the bank
currently
yeah i have about two thousand saved up
way to go you are so far ahead of most
american adults so i'm really proud of
you that's incredible you got a great
work ethic at 14 years old yeah what are
you thinking about for the future are
you thinking college or what's your plan
um so just work through high school and
then go on the two year mission and then
come back and go to college
awesome what are you thinking about in
terms of paying for college do you are
you starting to save for that
um yeah just you know work while i go to
college
nearing the summer cash flow college
i love it well ask your question should
i be investing any of this money right
now i want you to invest in luke and so
that may not look like a roth ira or an
investment account because there's so
many unknowns over the next
eight years of your life that when you
have a pile of money ready to go liquid
cash it's going to change how you make
your decisions and because you're not
sure what's next and what college looks
like and who's going to pay for it have
you had a conversation with your parents
about this
are they saving up for college
not much okay
um here's what i'm gonna do i want you
to go watch borrowed future with them
say hey mom dad movie night we're gonna
watch borrowed future we're gonna gift
that to you austin will pick up after
we're done here and make sure we get you
a code so that you can watch that i
would think that's gonna spark an
awesome conversation with you and your
parents because clearly it sounds like
you want to live your life debt-free
even at 14 years old you're calling into
the show you know what we say around
here
yeah and so my a1 for you is to get you
through college and get you a job
without ever touching debt without ever
touching a credit card because dude you
don't need one you're so sharp you're
gonna do so great you're going to build
so much wealth if you just stay on this
path and so i just want you to figure
out what those next plans are before we
go dump this money in retirement
accounts that you can't touch until
you're 60. you know what i mean okay
but luke you're doing awesome to be out
there creating a business running a
business making consistent income and
building your resume for the future
that's just incredible yeah i would just
park all the money you can in an online
savings account for now and over the
next five years who knows maybe at 50
000 and we go great we can actually pay
for college now and cash flow it because
mom and dad weren't able to help so we
just don't know what that future holds
and worst case if they cover college 100
you get scholarships you have 50 000 you
can now use as a down payment you've got
your emergency fund you're ready to
invest and you're going to go full
throttle at that point so i'm not
worried about you becoming a millionaire
it's going to happen if you stay the
course appreciate the call man thank you
so much
and joins us up next in austin texas and
welcome to the show
thank you very much
i just have a quick question and i'm a
believer in dave ramsey long before i
ever heard about him i saved i did all
kinds of things
and i've been to school ramsey school
but
there's just one thing i don't do that i
know
is not according to the plan and that is
i use my credit card
and
yes i do and because i like the perks
so yesterday i went out and i got a real
nice computer which i needed
and charged it i have the money in the
bank now to pay for it and i do pay off
my credit card every month
okay
if i if i
pay it now before it goes through the
next cycle the next month will i still
get my perks
or will they just wipe that off
well and i i'm kind of anxious to pay it
off not wait well i love the idea of you
paying it off i don't love the idea of
doing it so that you can get the perks
and so i'll answer it twofold i'm not a
credit card company so i don't know how
snakes work i don't know the inner
workings of them um
but you're not winning here what was the
perk that you went all right i'm going
to charge the laptop to the card what's
the perk you're getting for this
well i get money back a percentage of
the money i spent back
well last year i got about six hundred
dollars
okay
now take all that money and i need it
and if let's just say you could have
done better if you used your own money
do you think you would have made
different spending decisions at all if
you're going to be brutally honest would
you have made different spending
decisions if this was all coming from
your bank account and you got no perks
would you have spent less i don't i
don't almost think you can't do that i
think you have to do it wrong but i am
very frugal i'm not
crazy out there but yes i'm sure i did
i'm sure i did spend many i shouldn't
have um
well i'll tell you this i don't think
there's a difference if you pay it off
today or pay it off in a month i still
think you're still going to get your
pennies on the dollar for your uh cash
back that's changing your life
so you can continue to do that but i
would encourage you to make anne her own
cash back program where anne now has the
margin to give herself 600 bucks because
she has margin because she's doing an
every dollar budget she's using her own
money it's changing how she makes
decisions what do you think about that
how's that for a cash back program
that's a good one that's a very good one
i like this idea stop insurance every
other way here's a test dan what if you
cut up the card and for let's say one
month you just use your debit card
and you call me back and tell me if you
missed the perks and tell me if you
spent differently because of that would
you be willing i don't know if anyone
has ever done this test would you be the
guinea pig for us
i would love to oh my goodness okay ann
listen i want to call back one month
from now it's june 17th july 17th call
back into the show austin will
definitely remember anne from austin
texas and you're going to report back on
this experiment i want hard numbers
you'll get how much you spent and if you
missed the rewards because truthfully do
you have any debt and you said you pay
it off every month you you do everything
the ramsey way but the credit cards
yes the house has got the house is paid
the car is paid oh you're amazing
and you're crushing it
you don't need to be playing with snakes
you don't need this credit card you're
doing so well what's your income
uh well i have social security and i
have a small annuity from my retirement
okay and that's enough for you to have a
comfortable retirement
no
oh
well that's a problem what are we doing
to supplement that
oh well i've sold everything that moves
in the house my husband passed away and
he was making very good money but it
didn't come to me
so uh in in a moment i had
all of the bills and not much money to
pay for so oh my goodness well and
here's the deal here's what i'm telling
you right now the credit card companies
are not going to help you have a
comfortable retirement that 600 bucks is
not a gift that's going to bless you in
retirement so let's cut it up let's get
on a plan call me back in a month let me
know how the experiment went using your
own money i'd love to hear about it i
love this experiment this is amazing
that puts this hour of the ramsay show
in the books
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host host of the
fine print and entree leadership podcast
joined today by fellow ramsey
personality and best-selling author
christina ellis and we are excited to
take your calls triple eight eight two
five five two two five
taylor's kicking us off in portland
oregon taylor welcome to the show
hey george hi christina thanks for
taking my call absolutely how can we
help
um so quick back story is um during this
year we got more in line with the ramsey
plan and my wife and i are currently on
baby step two so we caused investing
extra mortgage payments
our two debts um working on
my wife she's buying into her practice
this year and we plan on having that
done by the end of this year
and then the next one to choose after
that resuming her med school payments
and getting that out of the way and then
we'll be debt-free
um
so we're expecting another child next
year
and
so as we're
you know with my wife i'm being a
business owner we're learning what it
means to pay
quarterly taxes and estimating
withholdings et cetera um
so
next year she won't be paid while she's
on maternity leave and at the same time
she'll go back to work part-time during
the first year of our child's life
that's what she did with her daughter
and she wants to do that again so it
looks like a big drop in income next
year
so this year even though we're not
experiencing her big increase in income
because we're on baby step two um it's
obviously gonna be more and so my
understanding is when it comes to safe
harbor laws and contributing 110
um to avoid penalties based off the
previous year's income
so
i guess my question is is it all worth
considering trying to budget and
contributing to any of our pre-tax
retirements again to decrease our tax
burden for next year since we're
anticipating a drop in income
no i don't i just don't think that's
going to be the the life hacking
shortcut that it seems to lower your tax
burden so what's your income starting at
this year what's it going to go to
um it's significant increase this year i
don't know exactly because this is the
first year
you know
she's going i mean it's going to be
somewhere between three and 350. awesome
i can say this year we're just we're not
experiencing because i mean we plan on
having 150 000 paid off in just this
year alone and then getting the rest of
that school
total
um total i have to look right at her med
school is under 100 i believe we're at
90 still i have to go back and look at
our chart
um
but we were able to pause that
because it was a personal loan that was
zero percent we paused it we said hey
we'll pay extra once we finish this
buy-in
and then we'll be done with it at the
same time we anticipated um so are you
guys doing the debt snowball it sounds
like we're doing
a little different plan
are you doing them small is the largest
regardless of interest rate
um
no and that's you know we started this
way before we kind of uh listen to you
more as far as what the death snowball
means um the reason why is
there was a little we just did it
because it's a bigger one a little bit
of interest and my wife personally
wanted this one done when she goes on
maternity leave with her practice and
then since the other one was through her
family it was just an easy thing hey can
we pause this and then come back and
just have it done at the start of next
year at a higher rate um so i guess
technically no here's what i'm feeling
for you guys uh taylor you're doing a
lot of once and if you start investing
and we're paying off some of the debt
but it's not the smallest one we're not
really feeling the progress and so my
worry is she goes on maternity leave the
income goes down and you're exactly
where you were with no money and having
all these payments in your life so if
i'm in your shoes i'm going we can
ratchet this up we can get really
intense let's do the debt snowball let's
follow the proven plan that millions of
people have done and realize that we're
not as unique or special as we thought
we were and i think you're going to find
yourself in a very different place if
you do that
sure and i will i'll tell you one
clarifying thing we don't plan on
pausing even paying any debt payments
with the child i know in the past it's
you know or when i've listened to the
show you talk about um
uh you know pausing baby step two when
it comes to having kids um yeah and i
was trying you guys have money in the
bank
um we do it's tight just since we're you
know still
basically on her side of things we're
only holding her income to pay for uh
basically quarterly taxes that we're
living off my income okay do you have an
emergency fund
um the bare minimum uh you know it's a
little over a thousand but you know we
don't have three to six months though
how much do you have left with paying
into the practice
um
we will start with 150 we've at the end
of this month we would have paid 90
and so
uh yeah you say 60. you have 60 left and
then how much do you have left in um
other debts
um it's just for med school um it's i
believe it's 90. i think i look at mike
i have to go look at the chart again we
haven't looked at it because we decided
to put everything kind of towards this
practice have it done in one year and
then get back with the med school and
then be done with it so between the two
150 total between those two
okay and you said that you paid 150 last
year is that kind of like no i plan on
150 this year sorry
we started um we kind of wearing this
thing january 1st of this year that's
when she started you know being a owner
um and so that's when we kind of went
full steam ahead with uh the buy-in and
just to have that out of the way and
then next year have the payment so at
the end of this year it'll be 150. okay
so do you guys know your debt payoff
date like between everything and on the
current path you're on when will you
have the debt completely paid off we
didn't write it down because when we
have another kid i just wanted to leave
some leeway we planned i planned on i
said one to two years and we didn't make
an exact date just because we didn't
know how impacting it having a child if
we don't know if we wanted to be
prepared if um you know see if the
pregnancy doesn't go as planned or
there's other medical costs um and
safely it forces having to stop it's in
order to pay medical bills if something
happened i don't anticipate it but just
in case i would definitely have some
money
socked away
for this baby and make sure that mom and
baby get home healthy and then if they
are we can throw that money on the debt
but i definitely would uh i love that
you're intense about the debt but i also
don't want to leave you guys in a lurch
where you have a thousand dollars in the
bank and you have you know medical
emergency happen right luckily i have
paid leave um so you know i still have a
job and i paid leave all we're off and
that's what we do with my last daughter
and we since it went well uh we were a
little off my income even during that
time so
okay
well i like you guys doing the debt
snowball maybe stocking away five or ten
thousand dollars until baby and mom are
home safely then you can throw that on
the debt if that's the case
um and i know you want to invest i don't
think the tax credit's going to be worth
it it sounds like you're trading a
dollar for a quarter and so i don't
think it's going to alleviate a lot of
the the tax burden but i would talk to a
tax pro you can jump on
ramseysolutions.com and get in touch
with one of our endorsed local providers
in your area to make sure that we're not
missing anything here on the fine print
sure
sure i appreciate it yeah it's all new
for us with her being an owner and how
we're trying to withhold quarterly so
it's just trying to get some advice it's
all new for us yeah well i'm pumped for
you guys excited for the for the baby it
sounds like this uh medical practice is
gonna be just going zoom zoom soon
christina so this is a good situation
big shovel this debt is gonna be cleaned
up soon but i think following the debt
snowball is where they're going to see
the most progress absolutely yeah
congratulations y'all from the new baby
and it's obvious with the way the
practice is going to work out once you
get this debt paid off you're going to
be able to pour gasoline on this fire
and just really amp up investing which
is awesome that's what i'm here for
y'all this stuff works i'm telling you
and i know it sounds like i'm just cocky
and arrogant to do the dead snowball but
it's because i've met way too many
families on the debt free stage and i
don't where are all the avalanche
debt people who are going i paid off my
debt from highest to lowest look at me
now i'm debt-free you just lose steam
well and you did it yourself like you
were walking proof of it you saw how it
worked in your life and now you're baby
step seven living the dream that's why
i'm so excited about this stuff and i
want that for every single family
especially these young couples out there
man you can really make some progress
when you get on the same page and you
follow this plan you got a paid for
house in your 30s life looks different
that's what i want to help create this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
christina ellis is my co-host today i'm
george campbell and we are here for you
america taking your calls triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right christina so on the show we like
to have some fun we like to react to
some videos out there floating around
the interwebs and our team brought this
one to my attention and i thought it was
a fascinating
anecdotal video that can teach us some
things especially to the to the young
people out there gen z millennials who
are trying to make a buck and make it
fast which leads to some short-term
thinking so i thought we'd play this
video and get your hot take on it you
ready let's do it let's play it
if you had the choice between a million
dollars cash and your option of getting
a magic penny that doubled in value
every day for 30 days would you know to
pick the right one let's find out one
you'd have a penny the next day you'd
have two pennies
the next day you would have four pennies
day eleven we have ten dollars and
twenty four cents day twelve twenty
forty eight number sixteen three hundred
and twenty seven dollars sixty eight
cents
day seventeen six hundred and fifty five
dollars and thirty six cents number 21
10
485 dollars 76 cents day number 24 you
have 83
886 dollars and eight cents day number
27 we have
671 088 dollars and 64 cents
and on day 30 we have
5.368 million dollars
and 12 cents wow
what an interesting little study there
so the question was i could give you a
million dollars today or give you a
magic penny that doubles every day now
most people if i ask if i went on the
streets of nashville with a microphone
and said hey what would you take most
people are going to take the million
dollars right right would you agree
because they're not thinking about the
power of the compounding growth
of that penny right and i think it's
true of our society these days as i
watch a lot of videos on social media
and it's all zero down this you need to
get on this and passive income and
here's how to make this much money today
and a lot of it stems from people are
strapped with debt and they're looking
for an easy way out right they can't
think that far out they're thinking
about this weekend not five years from
now right delayed gratification that's
what it's all about i mean being willing
to say you know what i'm not going to
take you know this thing right now that
seems so obvious and easy but i'm going
to put it in investments and i'm going
to wait for it to compound and become
something amazing yeah putting that
million dollars even in a great
investment you're not going to get to 5
million within 30 days right well the
thing is is a lot of people you know
they're they're not willing to wait for
that they're they're willing to they
want to spend the money right now
they're not even just taking the million
and investing it they're just going i
want to use it right now for this or
that and it's like to be willing to
let your money make money for you is so
powerful absolutely so i'm taking the
penny i don't know about you
i'm taking the penny i'm in now if you
said i'll give you a million or you can
have 5 million in 30 days it changes the
equation i'm like oh okay easily
everyone's gonna say i'll take the 5
million in 30 days hopefully right
but when you say a magic penny it
doesn't sound like much and that's kind
of true when it comes to investing
you're putting a little bit away every
single month and you're going 50 bucks a
month in an investment account that's
going to make me a millionaire
and you go well over 40 years it does
but most people would go nah it's not
even worth it i'm just gonna throw it
over here i'm gonna spend it i'm gonna
put it in crypto
but the boring thing is usually the best
thing that's what i've found right it's
like dave was talking about earlier in
the week where it's like what's easy now
can be hard in the long run and if
you're willing to do what's hard now it
can equal easy in the long run so if
you're willing to take that money and
invest it and you know make some
sacrifices you may not you know spend as
lavishly right now but it can provide
security and an amazing bank account in
the future it's like it is worth it
doing what's hard now making the
sacrifices putting the money away
equals easy later doing what's easy now
and just spending the money and not
saving not taking advantage of compound
interest equals hard in the long run so
it's like be willing
to do hard now so that you can do easy
in the future amen
yes that short short-term sacrifice
leads to long-term gain and short-term
thinking usually leads to long-term pain
there's your rhyme for the day there you
go that's good i love it well thank you
for indulging me with that video
i thought it was fun i was like oh it's
amazing to see how quickly it grows yeah
and you know as you get older and you've
got a million dollars in that investment
account it's amazing how quickly it
turns to two million
but it took you a long time to get to
that first million so have delayed
gratification think long term you'll
thank a slider good stuff john joins us
up next in new orleans john welcome to
the show
hey thanks for having me what's going on
i had some questions with the current
situation with the student loans and
whatnot
my wife and i were both teachers i never
made much more than
poverty line really into the last couple
years i got out of
the educational system and got into a
sales environment
and we've paid off forty five dollar
forty five thousand i'm sorry and credit
cards thirty thousand in personal loans
um we are down to a hundred and ninety
five thousand and student loans we both
have advanced degrees 195 in student
loans and uh 215
on our mortgage uh 15 year at 2.25
percent and so
um the real reason i'm calling is we are
in a time of zero percent
uh just a pause on student loans um and
we are up because we can do
retroactively we there were some things
we didn't understand about the payback
programs because we did the public
servant thing so we're under review
right now to see if we qualify for all
those years we were teachers and didn't
get credit for it under the public
service because we didn't know that was
a thing we really didn't do our research
that's our own fault and i want to know
like how you guys would say to proceed
uh you know we have a farm other than
that
this is this is to the last payoff thing
should we wait until
you know we receive uh credit or to find
out the decision and it could be you
know several months so you said you're
under review right now um are you did
you have a certain length of requirement
for how long you had to be a teacher in
order to get that and have you met that
well it was public service so it was any
non not for profit and it was uh we we
it was 10 years paying under that
and the new law that was just passed
said that they can go back and review
retroactively as long as the application
is received by i think it's october or
something and you did 10 years of
service correct
i'm actually at like nine years right
now and i'm still a not-for-profit
situation it's just i got into a
different i'm not education anymore my
wife is still in education so the
current job still qualifies potentially
for this forgiveness
okay yes
it's tricky because so much is changing
right now right so many you know
laws there's temporary benefits there's
talk potential major forgiveness it's
just a very confusing industry and we're
getting that question a lot you know do
we pay it off do we take the chance do
we see um but on the flip side
the interest is paused right now so it's
such a great time to be paying down on
student loans this is a really great
time to get ahead um now you said you
have 195 000 in student loans would that
is the whole 195 under review
yes yes it's all public student loans
none of it is private and have you
received any timeline for when this
might go through
so as long as we have our application
submitted by october and uh the woman
was very frank on the phone that this
could take a while so
um they said they said they could get a
decision as quick as 30 days but i've
never had anything with the government
that moves quick at all so right and
interest is still accumulating in the
meantime right
um
is that zero percent well once we hit
once we hit august interest is going to
be accumulating right
right so if i'm in your shoes i'm
starting to carve out space in my budget
again for that payment i'm starting to
think through how am i going to attack
that payment i'm not waiting for the
government i'm not waiting to see what
they're going to do you know i'm i'm
thinking about how am i going to pay
this off as quickly as possible now i
know a lot of people are nervous because
they're like what if what if it gets
forgiven and i paid off my student loans
and then i missed the opportunity for
forgiveness if you're in that situation
and you're concerned about it then i
would still start putting the money
aside in a high-yield savings account so
that you know if it doesn't get forgiven
you have that money set aside to
immediately pour onto your loan and
potentially get it as quickly paid off
as possible yeah that was gonna be my
suggestion to john it's just sock money
away in a savings account and 30 days
from now and they go nope sorry you
don't qualify you go cool
i have 40 grand in a savings account i'm
gonna start attacking the student loans
myself but in your situation when you're
so close it may be worth seeing the
review and maybe it does get forgiven
i'm not mad at that be awesome yeah yeah
thanks for the call john this is the
ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
when our team gets together here ramsey
solutions we talk a lot about our
mission to change america's toxic money
culture
it makes us real mad to see people get
trapped by debt or watch kids sign away
their future for student loans and for
the folks who work here this is not a
j.o.b this is a mission to change lives
and if that sounds like a passion you
share you've got to check out all of the
exciting roles ramsay solutions is
looking to fill asap there's never been
a better time to find a job doing work
that matters we need developers ux
designers and writers to help us build
digital products that actually change
people's lives you can check out what
it's like to work for us before you
apply just follow us on instagram and
facebook by searching ramsey careers and
if you want to apply for your dream job
at ramseysolutions.com
careers now is the time to do it ramsay
solutions dot com slash careers
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
campbell joined today by christina ellis
lincoln joins us up next in philadelphia
lincoln welcome to the show
hey thanks taking my call absolutely how
can we help
um i'm 16 and
i want to learn how to set myself up for
success financially i love to hear you
around for
yeah i make around four thousand a month
and i have about four thousand the bank
wow what are you doing for work
uh i work i work for a family company
and i've been working since
i was like 14 so wow and you're making
48 grand at 16 years old
that's correct
wow what kind of work is this
uh it's for restaurant maintenance
cool
good for you man and so you have 4 000
in the bank it sounds to me like you
don't have any debt and you don't plan
on getting any
nope i would i wouldn't stay away from
that if i can but wow what do you want
to do in the future is this like a
career and a job that you want to
continue on or are you thinking about
going to college and changing it up
um no i don't want to go to college i
know that i'd rather i like i like
working um i i wouldn't mind staying
with the business i like working on
automotive stuff i do i side like on the
side hustle i uh i flip cars i buy and
sell cars and i fix them up and i sell
them so
i could do something like that but for
now uh i'm just gonna stick with this
business so
very cool so it sounds like you want to
just follow an entrepreneurial path
in general so is college maybe not in
the picture for you right now
no it's not okay so if we're not worried
about that that takes away a large
expense in your near future so i mean
this stage of life do you have any
expenses you're living at home right now
living at home yeah now i'm just banking
all the money
i just looked into a 401k and i'm just
curious they matched the company matches
three percent of whatever i put in so
the company you're working for right now
yep yeah oh awesome
well absolutely if you're able to do
that i don't know the restrictions at 16
years old of when you're eligible for
that i know the roth ira is 18.
so i would look into that on the 401k
side
yeah and
do you have an emergency fund right now
um
not sure exactly what that is but i have
like four thousand the bank roughly so
that's a good start so i mean i'm
guessing you don't have a lot of
expenses right now but you might in the
next few years uh if you move out of the
house right
yeah correct okay so i would make sure
to get that you know maybe take that 4
000 up to 8 000 and then call that your
emergency fund for right now until you
have more real life expenses as you kind
of go out on your own as an adult
but beyond that emergency fund i think
it's really cool to start investing take
advantage of that match that's going to
be 100 return instantly on your money so
i love that start there and if you've
got any roth options roth is going to be
tax-free growth so you're going to use
after-tax dollars but then the money's
going to grow tax-free and if you invest
that in a roth ira or a roth 401k
and invest in good gross stock mutual
funds you're going to be a millionaire
probably my guess is by your early 30s
at the latest if you follow this plan
okay
and then on top of that once you're
investing 15 of your income into
retirement accounts then you can start
going all right let's save up for a down
payment on a house once we got that
plate spinning and now at you know 22
years old who knows maybe you could pay
cash for your first house
okay yeah i mean i i want to i'd want to
get out and
go on my own at 18 so cool so i would
rent first so maybe rent somewhere for a
few years while you keep saving up and
saving up but if you keep living on less
than you make like you are right now
you're gonna be just fine the fact
you're even calling with this question
at 16 years old gives me a lot of hope
for you
okay yeah yeah let's get him into ramsay
plus because we are you working on a
budget right now do you have a budget um
no i really just i just started
listening all your podcasts and so i
just thought i'd give you a call at a
question about that
curious where's all your money going
right now you're making foreground um
yeah i i wanted uh i wanted a classic
car when i was like younger so i i
bought a classic car
and so the money is kind of in the car
how much is the car worth
probably around ten thousand dollars
okay well that's reasonable for your
income
good for you and you paid cash for it
yep awesome and that's your daily driver
yep
sweet well you sound like you're in a
good situation
what i want you to do is i think right
now you're making good money and you're
super young and what i want you to do is
make sure that you understand the basics
of budgeting and where your money's
going and so when ramsay plus when we
sign you up for that you're going to get
every dollar premium and i want you to
make your very first budget list out
your income on one side and all of your
expenses on the other and the truth is
you may not have a lot of expenses right
now and so whatever's left after that i
want you to sock away in a savings
account
and you can begin investing once you
have that fully funded emergency fund so
that's going to be your a1 let's get
another four thousand dollars in that
savings account and then we can start
investing 15 percent of our income uh
which for you is going to look like
let's see probably 7 500 or so
yep and then beyond that we're let's
save up for a down payment for the
future maybe some cost to kind of get
out on your own and rent somewhere
you're going to need probably first and
last month's deposit maybe some
furniture so i want you to set yourself
up in that way to where when you go out
on your own as an adult you're going to
be like this is easy
i have money this is great this is
awesome and you're not scared of working
and that's that's the number one
greatest skill you can have is a great
work ethic yeah and in that ramsay plus
membership you can go through fpu
financial peace university that really
walks you through the seven baby steps
that we do here at ramsey and right now
you're in baby step three developing
your emergency fund and you're about to
go into into four through six and then
hopefully soon you'll be on baby step
seven paying off a house and just being
in a really great spot but it'll give
you that foundation of knowledge so that
you really know
why you're doing what you're doing how
you're doing it and just having that
really strong foundation as you move
forward way to go man hang on the line
austin's gonna pick up we'll hook you up
with a year of ramsay plus which
includes all the videos on financial
peace university and our premium
budgeting tool every dollar our question
of the day comes from blinds.com find
out for yourself uh their 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
miss measure you pick the wrong color
they're going to remake your blinds for
free you're going to get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more just use the promo code ramsay to
get the best deal today's question comes
from amanda in new york we have a
sophomore in high school due to some bad
financial decisions on our part we won't
be able to help him with college how can
we help him not have to take on a huge
amount of student loans
oh i love this question so my story my
mom couldn't help me pay for college
financially and she sat me down freshman
year and had a conversation and was just
really real with me about money and was
like you know i don't have the money to
help you but i believe that you can go
to college and you can pay for it
debt-free you don't have to take out
student loans
so i want you to get inspired to figure
out how you're going to do it and it
really lit a fire in me i started
applying for scholarships and was able
to win over a half a million dollars in
scholarships and go to school debt-free
here's the thing having those
conversations early with your student
can be so helpful a lot of parents feel
uncomfortable they feel ashamed you know
in this question she says you know we
made some bad financial decisions and so
money can feel very shameful and
overwhelming so that can be tempting to
not talk to your student about it but
here's the thing a lot of students are
arriving at college age there's seniors
in high school and that's the first time
they're having a conversation with their
parents about money and they're going
i didn't know that my parents weren't
just going to cashflow my education and
then they're kind of panicked and more
likely to take on student loans but if
you're willing to have that conversation
when your student's a sophomore in high
school that is such a gift if you can't
pay for their education be real and then
inspire them to start thinking about
ways that they can go to college
debt-free whether it's scholarships
whether it's working for an employer
that offers incredible tuition
assistance whether it's going to
community college free first there's a
lot of different options for graduating
debt-free but start creating that
strategy early yes find that local
affordable school have the conversation
maybe help them get on a plan to apply
for scholarships where are you gonna
work part-time to pay for this man that
can be a game changer but it starts with
a conversation parents you gotta be
talking to your kids i know there's
shame and guilt and all kinds of baggage
you might have but you're gonna set
yourself your kid up for success if you
have that conversation as early as
possible this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell ramsay personality
and host of the fine print and entree
leadership podcast you can find both of
those on the ramsay network and wherever
you listen to podcasts joined today by
christina ellis and we are taking your
calls triple eight eight two five five
two two five kathy joins us up next in
denver colorado kathy welcome to the
show
thank you i appreciate you taking my
call happy to take it what's going on
well i'm 58 have not stayed for
retirement i've just recently
read the book and the baby steps book
and i'm through three
um
and i have about
50 000 in an emergency fund
and i just don't know and i have an
inheritance coming um in a couple of
months it's about a hundred thousand
um i owe about 180 000 on my house and
was wondering if i should use that money
to put toward my house i am making
an extra
almost an extra house payment per month
now and have been for the last six
months awesome what's your income
it's i clear about 4 000 a month
great
and you've got the margin you've got so
you said you're in baby step three
you've got no debt and a fully funded
emergency fund so you should be in four
at that point
oh yes i'm sorry yes um i
have about 50 000 saved in my emergency
fund okay it sounds like that's more
than six months of expenses for you
yeah about a year i just
didn't know where to if i should invest
some of that in my house or where i
should go from this point on yeah and so
you're getting a hundred thousand
dollars of inheritance in a few months
so what i would do if i was in your
shoes i'm taking whatever's beyond the
six months of emergency fund plus the
hundred thousand inheritance and just
throwing that at the mortgage
so like 125 toward the mortgage yeah i
mean that would leave you with what 55
000 left
right
that's a good place to be and you said
you're making an extra payment a month
and now a whole bunch more is going
towards the principal instead of
interest
okay and so then i would start to map
out okay in two years i could have this
mortgage paid off
okay if i can throw 25 at it a year i
don't know what's feasible for you maybe
two and a half three years
but that would be my next goal
and uh on top of that you are able to do
some catch-up contributions in
retirement do you have any retirement
options at work
no i'm self-employed okay well you still
got options i mean you've got the the
sep ira solo 401k so if i'm in your
shoes i would talk to a smartvestor pro
you can jump onto ramseysolutions.com
and click on trusted pros get in touch
with them to figure out what the right
kind of self-employed retirement plan is
right for your situation
and then i would start socking away a
bunch of money in there and i would
start doing 15 today and
whatever's beyond that you can uh
you know continue investing after the
house has paid off
okay
does that make you feel better for your
retirement because here's the thing once
you remove that mortgage payment it's
going to change what your retirement
looks like it's going to lower your
expenses
right d are you going to get social
security or their pensions what are you
what's your plan to actually retire are
you going to have to work for another 10
years
i probably will
and social security is all i don't have
a pension okay
well i would be about the business of
getting this house paid off let's start
investing 15 as soon as we can into some
self-employed retirement plans and then
once the house is paid off we can
increase that investing and really start
to ratchet it up as you continue to work
for the next decade and hopefully
fingers crossed that will be enough with
social security to cover all your bills
which you won't have a lot of because
you won't have any payments right
yes okay well that's my plan for you
kathy call us back if we can help along
the way and jump on ramsey solutions.com
get in touch with a smartvestor pro
kathy you can get there i know i can
kind of hear a little bit of hesitation
in your voice a little bit of concern
but you know you can get there
especially with an almost paid off house
you're going to be feeling pretty good
in a few years so thanks for calling and
we're rooting for you yeah and it may be
a different picture of what retirement
looks like it may not be lavish
vacations but you can cover all your
bills you can put food on the table and
no one can take anything away from you
because you own it all including your
house and that's a good place to be
appreciate the call lucas joins us up
next in fort mill south carolina lucas
welcome to the show
hi christina and george how are you
doing great what's going on
so i just had a question about so i'm on
baby step three right now i'm 19 years
old and i'm you know saving towards the
three to six months of expenses
and i just had a question about the uh a
thousand dollar emergency fund that you
save in the very beginning what do you
do with that once you're in baby step
three does that so is that set aside for
like smaller expenses or do you add it
to the three to six months of expenses
so once you have your all your debt paid
off you're paying off that three to six
months expenses that thousand dollar
emergency fund that was a starter
emergency fund so now you're building
out a full emergency fund so that
thousand dollars is part of that
emergency fund as you build it out yeah
so just add to it okay same question i
just wasn't sure i had it set aside in
cash and then i was saving um for
probably the last three weeks something
like that toward a separate emergency
fund so and i the question just kind of
popped in my mind if that was supposed
to go toward that or if it was separate
so that's it you're further along than
you thought yeah that's awesome man yeah
i mean you can do a local savings
account attached to your checking
account you can do an online high-yield
savings account that's where i park my
emergency fund but keep it in one place
and only call it the emergency fund this
is not another savings account for an
upgrading car because what happens is
you get a little confused as to what's
an emergency and what's not is it urgent
is it necessary and is it unexpected
that is a true emergency and once you
have that man you're going to have some
financial peace in your life love it
definitely that's what i'm that's what
i'm going for awesome thanks for the
call man will joins us up next in
birmingham alabama welcome to the show
will how you doing hey i'm doing good
how are y'all great how can we help
oh yeah i was just uh gonna give you all
calls so i started listening to this
show about maybe a year and a half
but uh i was kind of done before and
didn't know you know all the rules and i
had bought a car while i was in school
and um
so
right now i want to say i owe 10 000 to
it
and uh
during college when i started listening
to y'all i kind of got in that
saving mentality and i saved around
around thirty thousand dollars in my
savings and uh
my question is though i i went online
and kind of saw the value of my car now
and it's worth
a little bit more than what i bought it
for
so i was considering selling my car and
then just buying the next one in cash
and kind of getting around seven or
eight thousand
in return and i was going to see if
y'all wanted me to go ahead and just pay
my car off
or go ahead and sell it and try to get
that profit in return and just get a
lesser car so you owe 10k on it what is
it worth
um it's worth like 17 nine right now wow
so you could clear 8 000 on this like
you mentioned and then what would you go
buy right
and that's the question because um
i have enough cash you know just to go
buy one in cash especially after i sell
my car
so i was i kind of don't know what
that's what i was going to ask you all a
question like what kind of value of car
should i go get what's your income
um right now so i just graduated school
um it's around around 50 000. oh awesome
plus commission plus commission so and
this is all the debt you have is the car
later
um i also have some college loans too
that'll start i guess in six months or
whatever that'll
uh how much download
that'll be around 20 000. okay and you
have 30 in the bank
yeah so you're telling me
you could turn around take a 30k in the
bank and pay off your student loans and
the car loan today
yes i would say i'm just a little
nervous like
i've had that saving mentality out that
number in the bank just makes me feel
secure
you're not dude you owe 30 000 to people
that makes me feel insecure
right yeah i know i'm just worried it's
a false sense of security having that
money in that bank account
right and i i know that i knew that was
the real answer it's just you know i
don't
it's tough giving that money it seems
like i'm just giving it away but i know
it'll be better in the long run you
signed up for all that debt my friend
and uh once you pay it off you're gonna
feel a whole lot better so if i'm you
keep a thousand dollars and if you can
find that extra 30 on top of that just
pay off all the debt and then you can
make the decision if you want to sell
the car what do you think christina yeah
i agree with that and i mean it's a
pretty tough car market out there so
it's a little bit challenging to find
reliable cars so if you like that car
you have the money to pay off all the
debt and then you can start saving up
your emergency fund i think you're in a
really good spot even though i know it's
nerve-wracking to
pay off the debt to not see the savings
account quite as high i think you're
going to feel a lot more secure and
breathe a little easier knowing you're
completely debt free and you're really
young still so you've got a lot of time
to save build that back up invest and
really win with money
absolutely that puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books my thanks to
christina ellis my co-host all the folks
in the booth and you america we
appreciate you listening we'll be back
with you before you know
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsaysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
christina ellis here today joined by my
co-host george camel
y'all this is my first time in the
driver's seat so here we go
we're taking your calls today
825-5225
first up we have tyler calling from
tampa
hey tyler welcome to the show
hey how's it going hey
it's going great how can we help
so um my question is i just uh i just
graduated from
high school i got my diploma and all
that and i plan on going to school for
like the next year and a half to do uh
airplane mechanics
and um i was wondering because every i
keep getting two different answers
should i build credit or should i not
build credit to go and purchase a house
okay and who are those two answers from
well my grandparents are there's
grandparents who say get credit and
grandparents and say don't get credit oh
which ones do you like more
that's a good question i won't make you
answer that i'm sure you love them both
dearly
well you called into this show i assume
you've listened before
yeah i remember going home from
kindergarten my parents listening to the
show kindergarten i feel like i'm 90
years old now that's impressive
so what do you what do you think my
answer is going to be
no credit um why do you think that is a
house
because uh credit means i love debt
you just answered you should be hosting
the show today you're doing great so far
i did i did take a ramsey classroom in
high school oh i love it unfortunately
unfortunately i got uh expelled and uh
asked not to come back oh my goodness it
wasn't because of the personal finance
class though was it oh no no no no okay
hey but you're calling the show today
that shows you're still a great student
so tyler when it comes to credit you're
you're focused on hey i need this to get
a house is that right
yeah because uh what they're saying is a
mortgage company will oh you don't have
credit you don't have a buying history
sure but um i got i got lucky enough to
um or unlucky i got a settlement because
i got hit by a car oh my goodness and i
have i have a quite quite a bit of money
are you okay are you physically well
yeah i just broke my arm i got honestly
after pt i got more movement in my arm
than the other one oh good okay so how
much money do you have currently
i currently have sixty thousand dollars
and you have no debt
no debt at all do you have an emergency
fund
uh yes i do outside of the 60
yep you're amazing how old are you
i'm only 18. oh my goodness you're doing
great man and is that how you plan on
paying for your education
uh yeah with the six some of the 60.
okay well i would focus on that now we
don't need to worry about getting a
house yet i want you to get through
college completely debt-free and when
the time comes when you are ready to buy
a house which by the way if you graduate
college debt free you'll get there a
whole lot faster
so here's why i can say this with
confidence that you don't need a credit
score to buy a house it's because i did
it and i'm not special
i just followed a process called manual
underwriting you'll see it listed as a
no score loan and there's lots of
companies that do it the one that we
recommend that we've been recommending
for decades is called churchill mortgage
they're a national company and they'll
walk you through it and what it looks
like is they look at your real financial
picture hey do you have 12 months of
rental history
check
do you have a tax return to show us to
prove that you made money great do you
have utility bills that you've been
paying like your cell phone and internet
great
we will give you this mortgage
all right yeah that sounds great
it's that it's that simple and a lot of
people over complicated christina they
say well george you're not telling them
how long and it's so complicated and so
difficult it really wasn't there was
just a few more documents to hand over
it took a little bit more time it didn't
delay us getting into our house and it
set us up for success because we weren't
busy playing the credit score game right
yep and so i would recommend to tyler go
listen to we did an episode on this on
my podcast to find print it's episode
seven it's called the dirty truth behind
your credit score you can find that on
podcasts and youtube just search for the
fine print and that will open your eyes
we talked to someone at churchill one of
their mortgage loan specialists to dig
into this topic i love that you have
that personal experience with it too
that you are walking proof that it can
be done and tyler my other encouragement
is just to make sure you take student
loans off the table you know you have
that 60k you said it's going to pay for
part of your education but i know
there's kind of a question mark for how
the rest of it's going to come about so
be determined to do it debt-free you're
young you have no debt you've got a
great start but keep that mindset
especially with two different sets of
grandparents kind of competing telling
you different mindsets when it comes to
money pick the one that leads you to a
debt-free future boom stay determined on
that nailed it next up we have jamie
calling from atlanta georgia hey jamie
welcome to the show
oh thank you so much for having me how
can we help
well
i am a entrepreneur and i have gotten
myself in about fifty thousand dollars
in debt
and i am trying to figure out if
bankruptcy is my only option
well easy answer is no without even
knowing anything else about your
situation you're going to be okay how
much do you make
75 000 last year who told you bankruptcy
is the only option
well
i went and i have three businesses and
um i went and bought an off well got an
office leased an office space and it
really caused my business to
go like just to be in a detrimental
space i'm now my bit my bills have
gotten behind i've maxed out my business
and my personal credit card
and essentially i got the office space
so that i can run my insurance business
and my
nonprofit in the same office space so i
can have people come in and i don't have
to be in two locations well the funding
has yet to come in for the nonprofit and
i guess i it was poor planning on my
part
so what kind of debt is the 50.
um it's credit card and i have 22
000 left on my car
okay what's the car worth
um the car is worth 30 000.
what do you say
we sell this car to help you avoid a
whole lot more pain and suffering
because that will clear half your debt
right there
true so if you sell for 30 you owe 22
that leaves you with eight grand to go
get yourself a decent reliable car for
now okay and this isn't jamie's forever
car jamie's gonna upgrade once we're out
of debt we have an emergency fund and
the business is back up and running
okay because that leaves you with uh
half your debt 25 grand or so
yeah and making 75 000 how quickly can
we pay off 25 grand
within a year pretty easily we can do
that within a year so i want you to get
current on your on your bills i want you
to be proactive in contacting all the
credit card companies is it multiple
cards
yes okay be proactive communicate with
them say hey here's what i can do right
now i'm going to make my minimum
payments we're going to get ahead and
then you start paying extra once that
car is sold and now you've freed up a
car payment that you can throw at this
okay
debt
see how this is gonna get you out of
this now you don't have to file for
bankruptcy absolutely
far from it
and if you want more encouragement we
also did an episode about this on the
fine print podcast episode eight is
bankruptcy a quick fix for struggling
americans i hope that gives you some
encouragement along the journey call us
back when you're dead free
i love that but some of the time it's
just getting the options out on the
table right like back yourself into a
corner right you go i can't do anything
i'd file for bankruptcy no you can get
out of this jaime and guess what she's
the solution there we go she was a
problem but she's also the solution
there we go beautiful given that hope
and encouragement this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
christina ellis joined today by george
campbell
if you're a business or hr leader you
know your employees are dealing with a
lot my employee wellness team smart
dollar just did a study and found out
that living through one of the toughest
times in history sixty percent of
employees say their mental health has
gotten worse
half say their mental health keeps them
from doing their job to the best of
their ability
good leaders take their employees mental
health and wellness seriously because
it's good for your team and your
business when your employees are healthy
mentally so give your employees a way to
deal with their stress and put them on a
path to care for mental wellness john
deloney's anxiety relief checklist gives
your employees simple steps they can
take to relieve their anxiety so they
can start bringing their full selves to
work again to get john deloney's anxiety
relief checklist for your employees go
to
ramseysolutions.com anxietychecklist
again that's
com slash anxiety checklist
we're taking your calls today triple
eight eight two five five two two five
next up we have michelle calling from
chattanooga hey michelle welcome to the
show
hi um
yeah thanks how can we help
well so
my husband and i are in a interesting
situation we are not fighting in any way
but we have a rental home
and then the only other the only debt we
have is our mortgage so we have no debt
except our mortgage
and we are thinking about selling our
rental our renters are about to move out
and so this is the time that we would do
that and we're just not sure which way
to go we
kind of don't think there's a wrong
decision but we don't know which
decision to make
cool so what is the rental worth if you
sold it once they move out
um i've talked to several realtors in
the last few days three of
your real the ones you guys recommend
and uh the consensus is about 225 is
what we've been listed for okay what's
left on the mortgage
one
got the note
159
cool so you'd clear that mortgage and
you have no other debt and you have
savings in the bank you have an
emergency fund
yes
do you guys have a money socked away in
retirement
oh yes how much it's a lot less right
now
oh goodness it's down to about 400 000.
okay that's your total retirement
savings
yeah it was at about um
eight hundred thousand and then the
market started going down
well it didn't go down 50 michelle
well
no
i may not have those numbers exactly
right okay so i don't have that it
pulled up in front of me all right yeah
it's definitely down from where it was
sure and we have not taken any out well
we're going to ride this out you guys
are both still working
yes okay what's your income
um including our rental about a hundred
and seventy thousand okay how about
without the rental considering the
renters are about to move out
um well we'll go to 150 okay yeah so the
rental
it's bringing about 18 000 a year okay
so not life-changing money this is not
going to change your lifestyle
drastically if you sell it
no it's not it's just it's a matter of
do we want to be out of debt now or out
of debt in three to four years yeah
because that's our new goal is getting
out of the mortgage i think both are
fine options it sounds like you're real
excited about having no mortgage payment
and i don't blame you
i am i am and my husband's not opposed
to it he he's excited too about that in
the future but we just want to
use our money
the wisest we can because it's not our
money it's not even our rental house
it's god's rental house
what should we do with it so we're
trying to get all of the information
well i love that mentality so if i'm in
your shoes i'm probably selling the
rental there's nothing wrong with
keeping it i mean it's paid for it's not
draining you guys and it's bringing in a
little bit of income but the idea of
having it paid off i have a paid off
house and a bunch of money in the bank
that you can now use to do some
contributions to retirement to really
set you guys up that excites me more
than being a landlord personally
yes and if you miss it you can always be
a landlord later right you can get
another rental property with cash
yeah and i feel like your your voice
just lights up whenever you talk about
the idea of having no debt and getting
it paid off so i feel like you're kind
of wanting to lean towards selling the
rental and paying it off i just think
that you're going to be able to walk in
so much more freedom yeah all right so
this is doing great still so let's sell
that thing yep next up we have andrea
calling from gainesville
hey andrea welcome to the show
hi thanks for taking my call
is it andrea
yes oh okay hello fancy flair to it
there we go we got it how can we help
um yes i am receiving a settlement from
a car accident i was in
a couple years ago and they need to know
what to do with the money i don't want
to have it just sit in my bank account
doing nothing
i'm on baby step four five and six
so our only debt is our mortgage
um i will need to access some of that
money for ongoing treatment but
definitely not all of it
how much money support on where did it
it's going to be about 30 000 okay
and you guys are currently investing 15
do you have kids
yes and you're putting a little bit of
money away for college
yes are you paying extra on the house
right now
um you're not okay how much do you think
you'd need to cover your upcoming
medical expenses
um
i'm thinking like about
a
thousand
um for the next year or two yeah just
co-pays and stuff like that i probably
could cash flow it um but it's nice to
have that question
yeah and you have your fully funded
emergency fund outside of that right
correct
okay
well if you feel like college is being
properly funded right now you could
throw a chunk in there into you know the
529 or esa whatever you guys got going
on uh but beyond that i would just throw
it at the house and start to knock out
this mortgage
okay what's left on the mortgage
uh
like 180
okay
that'll help what's your income now
we're creeping down i'm creeping down
i'm a little under 100 000. cool
yeah that's going to get you guys a long
ways throwing it at the mortgage if
college is doing well you're investing
15 you've got the medical expenses
covered i think that would be the next
step
what do you think christina okay yeah i
think that sounds great and i think
you're going to just keep you know
feeling better about having that
mortgage paid down i love that you're
already in a great path you're paying 15
into retirement you're saving for kids
college and yeah i think that sounds
like a solid if you were gonna park the
money i would just park in an online
high-yield savings account you're gonna
get about one percent which is nothing
nothing exciting but if you needed to
park any savings for now like the
medical expenses that's where i would
park it rather than that i'm throwing at
the house i want to see that mortgage
you go down less on interest more on
principal that excites me yeah thank you
so much for the call yeah thanks for the
call
next up we have makita calling from
jacksonville hey welcome to the show did
i pronounce that right
yes you did thank you so much awesome
how can we help
yes so bottom line up front i'm in the
military and i want to know should i
downsize my house next year when my son
graduates high school
now i might pcs next year i don't know
they may keep me here for my twilight
tour i have no idea but my son he'll be
a
senior he graduates and he may go to
college in north carolina he may not he
may go back to georgia where we're from
so should i downsize my home
oh i'm a fan of of selling it if you
don't need all the space and it's going
to help set you up financially could you
rent for a while until you figure out
what's next
um i could it might be harder down here
because of hurricane florence still um
the rental market is
like not as good as it was but i'm
pretty sure i can look for
an apartment to rent how much money
would you get from the sale of the house
net profit
um
maybe
30 40 000 i'm not sure okay
i mean if you want to put that down on
the next house i think that's fine but
it sounds like there's so many unknowns
in your life right now that you're not
really sure where you're going to be
planted
which is why i'm okay with you spending
a little bit more on rent because of
those unknowns
okay okay
yeah it's a four bedroom and it's only
two of us so i don't want all that space
oh yeah you don't need four bedrooms i
would sell it i would rent for a while
maybe for a year figure out where you're
going to be planted long term and make a
decision based off of that
that's a good question thank you for the
call we're taking your calls at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
christina ellis joined today by george
campbell
so christina we both purchased used cars
this year and we thought it'd be fun to
give our listeners some tips because a
lot of people are going listen i know
it's not a great time to buy a car but
we need to get a car right and so we
want to make sure that they avoid so
many traps out there and there's a
thousand ways these days to even get a
used car so we're gonna talk about our
personal experiences what we've learned
and maybe give some encouragement to
those looking to get a car yeah
absolutely it's rough out there man i we
had been saving for a car for a long
time we saw the market and we thought
you know
let's just wait because this is just too
crazy but then the ac went out on our
2008 ford escape with 200 000 miles and
we were kind of forced in that position
where it's like oh hey no now is the
time we got to buy a car now and just
going into this market it is insane out
there and so yeah we learned a lot
through the process that i think could
help other people who are kind of going
through this yeah and one of the biggest
things that i learned in this is just to
watch your emotions so i went to
probably over 50 different dealerships
here in nashville trying to find a car
called around everywhere just trying to
find inventory find what we're looking
for
and
it's emotional it's really hard because
you think you know i've got the money
saved up to buy a car why can't i find
the car or why are all the cars marked
up five ten thousand dollars and it was
interesting because i had some dealers
kind of put that you know slimy sales
pressure on and i asked one dealer i
said you know how on earth do you think
you know you could get 20 000 over msrp
for a used car when new cars are going
for less than that and he actually said
you know so many people are desperate
right now that they're willing to just
come on the lot and when they see a car
they're just going to jump on it and get
it in that moment so
just being willing to go
okay well there's not a lot of cars out
there there's a lot of crazy pricing
just taking a breath and saying you know
while this dealership is low on cars
there are other dealerships out there
that could potentially have a car and
just trying to keep those emotions and
just like the housing market you get
stuck on a certain kind of house or this
feature or this make and model and you
start to do stupid because you're like
this is the old this is it this is the
only car like this that exists we had a
call ken coleman and i on the show and
someone said what was the uh schnozberry
color jeep and they were like well we
have to have it because it's the only
schnozberry colored jeep with and i was
like it's a maroon jeep guys there's
other maroon jeeps out there but people
make crazy decisions based on their
emotions so we gotta take the emotions
out and go no what do we actually need
right right now what do we need right
now another thing is is to watch out for
hidden fees so when we were shopping for
cars i came across this car that looked
like it was such a great deal it was
like 2 000 under kelly blue book and it
was beautiful we were so excited about
it about to purchase it and i asked
thank god i just had this idea to ask
for a printout of the pricing and said
you know we're gonna go home and think
on it for the night we'll come back
tomorrow if it's still here and when i
looked at the pricing there was this
random three thousand dollar extra fee
it wasn't taxes it wasn't title it
wasn't licensed it was this mystery fee
so i called back the next morning and
was like what is this fee and they're
like it's it's a pre-maintenance fee
we're charging you for stuff that we did
in in advance and i'm like i don't i
don't want to pay that fee and after you
added that fee in i wasn't getting a
deal it was over kelly blue book it was
not a deal so just watch out for that
what might seem like a deal in this
market and very exciting because there's
not a ton of deals could actually not be
a deal once you actually realize like
the final pricing and most people at
that point they're so deep in it they're
not even really looking over the sheet
they're just going it's been three hours
i want to just get out of here and get
in this car and so you got to watch out
for all of those random fees and they
are random i follow some some car
dealership guys out there that help
people avoid these traps and they're
going through going the only legit fee
is a small dock fee a small one under a
thousand dollars that's it other than
that you should only be paying your
sales tax your tax
those kinds of basic fees on top of the
actual sales price so when i got my used
car i was so excited because it was just
the sales price plus tax that was it and
i went
i can breathe yes this is good so make
sure you watch out for those hidden fees
and just say i'm not paying that and if
they go okay kick rocks you walk away
and usually they're chasing you in the
parking lot going okay sir sir we're
going to cut those fees i talked to the
manager in the back they're always
having to go to the back to this
mystery manager which is really just
them taking a smoke break and going all
right i'm going to go back out there
and wheel and deal a little bit more
right well a lot of times when you see
those fees you're already like sold on
the car so by the time you get that
pricing print out you're already
picturing yourself dropping your kids
off at school in this car and taking
vacation in this car so it's like before
you really decide this is our car make
sure you ask for a printout of the
pricing so that you truly know before
again you get your emotions wrapped up
in buying that specific car and you got
to do your research ahead of time to
even know is this actually a good deal
is this a fair price and so i want you
to go to that dealership knowing more
about that car than they do absolutely
that is how you win in these
negotiations that's so good and the
other thing is to just keep looking so
you know in our situation our ac went
out on the car so it is tempting to get
desperate and it's tempting to go we
need a car today and we need a car right
now but if you can find a way to build
on a little bit of margin to give
yourself time to actually explore and
look and see what's out there that can
help so much and this is going to sound
really crazy and i can't believe i'm
admitting this on national radio but
we actually went on amazon and bought
two 25
little ac units to put in our old car to
give us a couple more days to search for
a car that is scrappy that's a pretty
gangster i'm looking at your husband out
there and he's giving me the thumbs up
yeah i was like man like i can't find a
car tonight but we still need a car so
what can we do to stretch this out and
give us some time and here's some
patience buy us some patience and the
cool thing is when we did finally find
the car that we were looking for it was
the cheapest one of its type within a
200 mile radius and i found it within an
hour of it being posted so having that
extra flexibility to look and explore
and take the time actually helped us
save thousands of dollars in the long
run and you're ready when that time does
come when you see that car and you go oh
we have the cash which is the biggest
tip of all pay cash do not fall for
their financing they'll go well we'll
take a thousand dollars off if you
finance it because they're getting all
their kickbacks of fifteen hundred
dollars if you finance it so avoid those
traps i don't know people say well wait
don't tell them you're paying cash
because they'll if they're not going to
sell me a car because i'm paying cash
i'm moving on i don't want to do
business with these people and when we
say cash we got to make this clear we
don't mean take a brief case of cash
which i've
someone i know actually took a briefcase
full of cash to the dealership and they
went we legally can't even take this
it's a liability we can't take over 10
000 so don't do that i'm talking about a
cashier's check yes that's the way to do
it when you have that
you can supplement that with your debit
card or with a with a personal check
because people go what if it's not the
exact amount to the penny in the
cashier's check it's okay you can
supplement that you'll be okay you'll be
okay so there's a lot of uh research
that has to be done and it can be
overwhelming so i want to give people a
few tools that they can use to start
their research online edmonds is a great
reputable site car gurus truecar of
course kelly blue book this is a great
way to figure out what kind of car do i
want what is a a fair price for what i'm
willing to pay for it then you know kind
of how much you need to start saving up
to pay for that in cash and there's a
lot of different sites for
buying to buying online cars as well car
gurus will show you local local market
prices carvana and carmax are great for
national market prices kelly blue book
is suggested retail value
your local dealer might give you some
anecdotal insight about what's going on
locally in your area so you combine all
these data points you go oh this gives
me a really good true picture of how
much this car should cost and what i
should be looking for that's so good
yeah of all times it's always good to do
your research it's always good to have
options but especially now in this
market it's good to go in with all of
your ducks in a row doing the research
in advance knowing what the price should
be for the car and just really being
able to come in prepared and last thing
always get a pre-purchase inspection
this has been a big one we've taken a
lot of calls where people buy a car they
thought it was a good deal and three
days later the transmission goes out or
it needs thousands of dollars in repairs
that they didn't know about
and all these cars are sold as is and so
unless you can take advantage of some
kind of lemon law you can get screwed on
these deals so always get a pre-purchase
inspection from a mechanic of your
choice do not let the person selling it
tell you oh yeah i'ma go to my buddy
here
because that's just not a trustworthy
way to go about it so find a local
mechanic that you trust to look over the
car it's gonna cost you probably a
hundred bucks 200 bucks but it's so
worth it to know that what you're buying
is exactly what you thought it was
exactly that's so good it's it's that
concept of taking the time in advance
you know taking the time to do the
inspection taking a little bit of extra
time to search to not get you know
panicked and desperate and kind of fall
into that trap of buying something you
know just because you're in a state of
needing it right then being willing to
breathe oh yeah do the inspection
here's what i found christina the person
with the most patience information and
options always wins so get you all three
before you make a giant purchase so good
we'll be back this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day is the lord
will fight for you you need only to be
still exodus 14 14.
our quote of the day is we do not have
to become heroes overnight just a step
at a time meeting each thing that comes
up seeing it not as dreadful as it
appears discovering we have the strength
to stare it down eleanor roosevelt that
is so good
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
christina ellis joined joined by my
co-host george campbell
so christina we got to talk about this
you are known for having gone to school
completely debt-free winning over half a
million dollar in scholarships cash
flowing your bachelor's degree your
master's degree just a great success
story and you're encouraging the next
generation to do the same to show them
that it's possible to go to school
debt-free
i am on the other hand the guy who did
dumb
went into student loan debt didn't have
the right conversations with my family
and ended up in 36 000 of student loan
debt kind of wandering into it going
okay i guess we're here and so i got rid
of that very quickly following the
ramsey plan but i wanted to talk about
some of the student loan myths that are
out there and i i kind of like that
people are riled up about student loans
because it shows me that we're breaking
the myth that student loans are quote
good debt
because if it's good debt why would we
be in the business of forgiving it right
right so america's waking up to this and
we're seeing some of the stats out there
47 of americans who use student loans to
pay for school have delayed other things
they want to do in their lives like
buying a home getting married or having
a child because of student loan debt
that breaks my heart that breaks my
heart too we've been on
some coaching calls recently with people
with six figures in student loan debt
and just hearing
what it's causing in their lives hearing
the pain in their voices the things that
they're putting off
i can't sit with saying this is good
debt when i see the way it's destroyed
lives and i see the people and the pain
on the other end of the line it's just
it's rough
and uh student loans are killing the
american dream and it seems like the new
american dream it feels too far away for
someone to be a homeowner and have this
kind of car now this the american dream
is can i be debt free in my lifetime
and so we're out here trying to preach
from the street corners going yes you
can and you don't have to wait your
whole life to become debt-free and the
average person that follows the ramsay
plan the baby steps the debt snowball
they pay off their consumer debt in 18
to 24 months because they get intense
and angry at it that's so powerful and i
love that you've walked through it that
we're coming from completely different
places so it's like you know i went to
college debt-free you had debt you paid
it off and we're both so passionate
because it's like this whole system of
college with student loans and people
getting gripped in student loans it's
not okay and we can help you all find it
whether it's paying off student loans or
going to college debt-free it can be
done but i think one of the things that
people are really frustrated about right
now we're talking about student loan
forgiveness which is great but we also
have to fix the problem
of how the new generation is going to
pay for college it's it's such a
challenge because it's like we have two
problems here it's like we've got people
gripped with student loan debt and then
we have people who are signing up for
more student loan debt so it's just so
important that we we stop the bleeding
and people start attacking the problem
figuring out how they can pay off theirs
oh yeah the forgiveness is we're trying
to bail out the water from the boat
without plugging the leak right and
that's a major problem and a boating
analogy coming from me that's impressive
right there
but according to ameritrade this is from
earlier this year the average student
loan debt per borrower is 38
792 dollars with the average monthly
payment coming in at almost 400
and 7 out of 10 graduate with student
loan debt around 45 million americans
walking around with this monkey on their
back 1.7 trillion dollars
and it just feels overwhelming it's what
i like to do is zoom in and go the
numbers are scary so what can we control
we can't control what happens in the
white house we can't control the
forgiveness programs but i can control
the guy in the mirror and i can get on a
budget and i can figure out where to
find the margin i can go get a side job
and i can take control of this instead
of hoping and wishing and praying that
someone does something about this
problem
right and well the thing is is right now
the reason it's so important to talk
about this is a lot of people haven't
been paying on their student loans for a
few years we have people who graduated
from college a year and a half ago and
they're not paying on their student
loans and the thing is is they didn't
know really what that was like to start
with they don't really know what it
looks like to put a student loan payment
in their budget and then we're hearing
all these promises about potential
forgiveness so they're hoping it's never
going to happen so
like you said you got to start attacking
it and looking at it and getting on a
budget so it's like even even if you're
sitting there waiting and thinking you
know i want to see if forgiveness is
going to happen you know i don't want to
pay anything until we see what's going
to happen you can still start setting
apart that payment and start getting on
a budget and carving out that space so
that you know you're ready regardless
because we saw a study and it's you know
i think it was like
90 some percent of people are not ready
to start resuming payments and that's a
scary statistic that's a scary thought
of you know all these people are going
to kind of be shocked when it comes back
if it comes back yeah we take a lot of
calls on the show people say hey should
i wait i mean what if what if
forgiveness does happen and the chances
of widespread just unlimited student
loan forgiveness happening in my
lifetime is slim to none now if they do
forgive let's say ten thousand dollars
we are barely going to make a dent
and it's not gonna affect all people
they're probably only it's gonna be
federal loans so if you got private
loans sorry
and the people who go well i don't want
to pay off my loans because what if they
get forgiven later and i've already paid
them off and i go well you just got free
earlier and it changed your character it
changed your work ethic it changed how
you view money and how you view debt so
i'm totally okay with you paying off
your debt and forgiveness happens later
on you go whoopty do happy for all those
people but the calls that we take it's
not ten thousand dollars in student loan
debt it's 50 it's 90. it's 150. and so
we're not even scratching the surface
and this is not a solution and also it's
a talking point as we headed to the
midterms yeah no matter what political
party it is this is a great way to get
voters excited to vote for you when you
can dangle that carrot in front of them
which is which is sad because it's a
carrot that's really confusing people
like the fact that there's not clarity
on this i think so many of us just wish
that they would decide one way or
another so that real people could figure
out you know what they're going to do
hey i wondering can you share a bit of
your story about how you paid off your
student loans because i just love it you
you
really hustled for this like the way you
made sacrifices i honestly kind of get
goosebumps when i hear your story
because i love it that means a lot so i
had 36 thousand dollars of student loan
debt got a communication degree
bachelor's of science and that and when
i got out i started working here as an
intern and attempt and i got an entry
level job
i went through financial peace
university and i saw other people around
me who were paying off their debt i went
oh you can just pay it off like faster i
thought it was a thing you just pay off
for 20 years and hope it's gone so i
went about the business and i did it my
first budget and i went oh my gosh i'm
spending 700 on food as a very small
single man this is a huge problem so i
started getting really intentional and
creative and going i'm gonna go to the
grocery store and wait till lean
cuisines go on sale five for ten dollars
because like that's two dollars a meal
and if i do that i can shave off so much
money on food and i started going to
downtown nashville not to party but to
pick up the party goers because i picked
up side hustles doing uber and lyft to
make extra money i love it and on top of
that i went what are my skill sets what
is my skill set what can i use my
talents for to make extra money on the
side and i was in marketing at the time
so i started building websites for
people and i became a marketing
consultant and i started getting paid
you know 25 30 an hour to do this work
from home
after work on the evenings during the
weekends and i really started to see the
momentum and i stopped eating out and i
got on that budget and i saw the
progress and 18 months later i was
completely debt free i had cut up my
discover card my american express card
that i was like but the delta sky miles
the five percent cash back at
restaurants from discover they're
blessing me with these amazing rewards
but why am i broke and unhappy and
miserable and filled with anxiety and
stress and frustration
and so once i cut those cards up got rid
of the debt
it freed me i mean i felt a weight lift
off my shoulders and this past december
me and my wife who works here we paid
off our house
and to get that weight off our shoulders
and go like i didn't think you know this
was 10 years ago that i was in this
position
i never thought 10 years later i could
be completely debt-free with a paid for
house with savings in the bank i just
thought that was that's for someone else
that's for rich people that's for
different kinds of careers that's not
for me so i want to encourage people
that they can get rid of this debt they
don't have to have it hanging around
they don't have to wait on the white
house to change their life they can just
be about the business of doing it
themselves and i think that is such a
powerful character changing spiritual uh
journey that they can set themselves on
that is so powerful you are willing to
do the work to make the sacrifices cut
back on your grocery budget work extra
jobs i mean you are walking proof of
what this plan can look like and the
freedom baby step seven that can come
from this that's just thank you
christine i love your heart for helping
this next generation avoid student loan
debt and show them how to do it you're
awesome
well that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books thanks to my co-host
george campbell and to the people in the
booth thank you and to you america
thanks for listening we'll be back with
you before you know it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you